monsieur champagne bonsoir merci d'être
là c'est un grand plaisir surtout en fin
d'année comme ça on se retrouve on est
là pour faire le bilan effectivement
d'une année qui a été assez chargée je
regarde vos occupations Japon Corée en
novembre récemment la Belgique
l'Allemagne vous avez beaucoup courtisé
la filiale la grande industrie de
l'automobile l'automobile électrique en
particulier quels ont été les gains qui
ont été faits pour le Canada chapitre
c'est souvent le chemin parcouru il y a
pas longtemps c'est une industrie qu'on
a battu toute pièce entre autres au
Québec avec mon collègue fait du début
dans l'Ontario aussi là maintenant le
Canada vous avez peut-être vu bloomber
Jack maintenant les deuxièmes au monde
derrière la chaîne devant les États-Unis
et ça commence à payer des dividendes
honnêtement on est ubsf à bécancourt on
regarde JM qui est revenu chez nous avec
Posco et là il y en a d'autres qui
viennent se greffer et je vous dirai la
meilleure anecdote que je peux dire aux
gens c'est quand j'étais au Japon à
Tokyo on parle de bécancourt maintenant
au Japon dans les grands constructeurs
ça veut dire que on s'est taillé une
place puis les gens pourquoi mais je
veux dire c'est simple c'est d'abord les
talents on sait que le Québec le Canada
on attire beaucoup de talents c'est ce
qui fait la différence deuxième chose
les écosystèmes aujourd'hui souvent
autant d'aérospatial que dans
l'automobile on a des écosystèmes forts
troisième chose des minéraux critiques
je leur dis toujours on ne toucher nous
là pour l'économie du 21e siècle que ce
soit les batteries les semis conducteurs
quatrièmement c'est l'énergie
renouvelable suivant le dividende de
Monsieur Bourassa parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui fait qu'on est capable
d'attirer parce qu'on veut décarboner
toutes les industries finalement l'accès
au marché parce que nous maintenant
monsieur Canada c'est pas 38 millions
c'est 1.5 milliards de consommateurs sur
une base préférentiel autant en Asie du
côté nord-américain que de l'Europe
alors quand vous mettez ça dans les mots
du PDG de Volkswagen de grands grands
patrons le Canada c'est le choix logique
le Canada oui traditionnellement
l'industrie de l'auto est plutôt du côté
de l'Ontario qu'elle pourrait être les
avantages là que peut mettre la vente
Québec par exemple pour les attirer
l'énergie renouvelable moi je vous
dirais c'est c'est probablement
aujourd'hui dans les 60 juridictions en
Amérique du Nord quand les gens
regardent le Québec entre autres les
gens s'intéressent beaucoup à ça parce
que l'idée pour moi c'est que un jour on
va passer du véhicule électrique au
véhicule vert moi ce que les
consommateurs veulent les consommatrices
pas juste électriques c'est vert alors
on veut des carboner toute la chaîne on
a commencé avec l'aluminium vous savez
aujourd'hui l'aluminium qui est produit
au Saguenay ça va dans les téléphones
Apple moi je rêve de voir ça dans
l'industrie automobile on le fait avec
avec l'acier vert moi je rêve de faire
des batteries vertes chez nos Québec des
semi-conducteurs verts on regarde du
côté des plastiques quand on a tout ça
donne une chaîne d'approvisionnement
complète pour les grands manufacturiers
puis je vous dirais ce qui est assez
fascinant c'est de voir l'intérêt pour
le Québec pour le Canada quand j'étais
en Allemagne c'est la première fois
qu'un Canadien je voudrais dire à
québécois est invité au conseil
d'administration de Mercedes Benz
imaginez un item à l'agenda c'était le
Canada pourquoi le Canada et c'était la
même chose avec Volkswagen qui a dit que
leur première usine de batterie en
Amérique du Nord il regardait très
sérieusement le Canada alors on est en
train de faire des gains significatifs
si l'année 2022 c'était l'un des
batteries 2023 ça va être les grands
investissements qui vont venir chez nous
on l'espère on va attendre de voir de
quelle manière ça se concrétise entre
temps on veut vraiment protéger les
intérêts ici Canadiens là je fais
référence à la Chine entre autres vous
avez décidé récemment de bloquer en
quelque sorte des entreprises chinoises
qui avaient des intérêts dans des
entreprises canadiennes liées aux
minéraux critiques
c'est pas facile à gérer ça les dossiers
des lits compenses à Saint-Clair d'une
filiale chinoise qui avait des intérêts
dans un contrat de la GRC on se demande
si la Loi canadienne sur
l'investissement le fait qu'elle soit
repentée est-ce que ça va venir
clarifier un peu les choses ça va aider
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça nous prend des
meilleurs outils il faut moderniser
cette loi là déjà plusieurs années et
l'aspect géopolitique a changé dans le
monde si après la chute du mur de Berlin
on se disait bah écoutez on s'en va tous
dans la même direction prospérité
stabilité prévisibilité on se rend
compte qu'il y en a qui avaient jamais
l'intention de nous rejoindre dans cette
rivière-là sur ce bateau-là alors là il
y a comme un mouvement quand vous
regardez dans nos alliés à travers le
monde une prise de conscience que la
géopolitique maintenant joue beaucoup
dans les conseils administrations
un peu partout puis les gens me disent
chacun c'est quasiment 50 % de nos
discussions qui est la géopolitique là
on parle de quand vous allez à travers
le monde on part de la sécurité
énergétique on part de la sécurité
alimentaire la résilience des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et là-dessus moi du
Bel Canada se positionne de façon
favorable parce que chez nous on offre
la stabilité la prévisibilité et souvent
quand les gens ont le choix ils veulent
aligner les chaînes d'approvisionnement
avec leur valeur et leur principe mais
en même temps vous savez les liens qu'on
a tissés on fait référence à la Chine en
particulier date de longtemps c'est
notre deuxième partenaire commercial
comment on fait pour se détourner
jusqu'à un certain point de ce marché-là
miser sur d'autres marchés mais
s'ennuyer aux entreprises québécoises
qui dépendent des expériences moi je
pense que quand même les gens doivent
avoir les yeux grands ouverts vigilance
lorsqu'on a vu des exemples vous avez
mentionné certaines choses qu'on doit
faire protection de la propriété
intellectuelle mais je pense que c'est
un moment vous savez il y a des moments
dans l'histoire comme ça il y a des
changements technologiques des
réalignements il y a des opportunités
générales et moi ce que je vois c'est un
réalignement des chaînes
d'approvisionnement on allait de chaîne
d'approvisionnement global on devient
plus régional on met plus d'enfants sur
la résilience et vous l'avez dit en Asie
Pacifique on a deux partenaires de choix
le Japon la Corée du Sud qui veulent
faire parce que vous savez ces deux pays
là ont besoin de tout ce qu'on a à
offrir donc oui il y aura toujours du
commerce avec la Chine mais moi je pense
quand on parle de chaîne
d'approvisionnement stratégique quand
vous parlez de minéraux critique quand
on parle de semi-conducteur moi je pense
que là-dessus on doit faire preuve de
vigilance et vous l'avez dit c'est ce
que j'ai fait quand j'ai protégé nos
mails de lithium chez nous au Canada et
je vous dirai ça a été applaudit à part
nos alliés à travers la banque qui
disent écoutez on veut voir ça parce que
notre le Canada le Québec c'est notre
partenaire de choix alors protéger ce
que vous avez comme ça on va pouvoir le
faire avec nos alliés à travers le monde
très bien je je vous emmène complètement
ailleurs parce que c'est passé plein
d'autres choses en 2022 dans le secteur
des télécoms d'ailleurs c'était les
plaidoiries finales au Tribunal de la
concurrence entre shy Rogers on s'attend
à une décision au cours des prochaines
semaines on présume quel scénario ferait
votre affaire monsieur Jean-Paul ben
écoutez moi d'abord il y a trois
processus en il y a le CRTC il y a le
Tribunal de la concurrence qui est un
processus judiciaire puis finalement il
y a le ministère de l'Industrie celui
que dirige alors moi ce que j'ai dit
vous savez j'ai déjà refusé le transfert
des licences comme on les appelle de
chat vers Rogers et j'ai dit que si
jamais on me soumettait une nouvelle
application ce qui a été fait pour le
transfert de chat vers vidéo tronc que
moi j'aurais des attentes très claires
pour les consommateurs parce que moi mon
rôle c'est de défendre l'intérêt public
alors j'ai dit de haut et fort première
chose il faudra que l'acquéreur de ces
licences là soit là pour le long terme
on veut pas de gens qui vont prendre ça
qui vont se tourner de côté rapidement
puis vendre ça à d'autres deuxième chose
on constate qu'au Québec imaginez
sont environ 20% moins cher au Québec en
Ontario dans le reste du pays alors j'ai
dit il faudra que les gens dans les
autres provinces puissent bénéficier de
ces mêmes tarifs là et ces attentes là
je pense vous avez entendu vidéo 30
c'est d'expérience on les comprend ça
c'était les attentes principales que
j'ai on verra quand le processus
judiciaire sera fini puis on verra si on
a besoin de mettre d'autres attentes
d'autres conditions je dirais pour se
transfert-là de licence mais c'est
certainement un dossier qui intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de gens au pays parce
que on le sait on veut plus de
compétition on veut des meilleurs prix
un moment où tout est devenu plus cher
moi je comprends j'entends des gens vous
savez des gens me le disent c'est vrai
du côté alimentaire c'est vrai au niveau
des téléthes partout clairement et on
attend qu'il descende et on attend de
voir comment il va évoluer vos dossiers
à vous monsieur champagne pour la
prochaine année que je vous souhaite
excellente merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci de m'avoir
invité joyeux Noël pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]